I've been a woman and a mother in
national security and if I got a dollar
for every time someone said more
aggressive in a meeting I would be a
very I would be retired and be a very
rich woman more aggressive tougher is
not a policy it's it's sort of crazy
talk what does it even mean and what we
have to remember is we are not under
anything close to an existential threat
right now we have a risk it is
heightened because of what's going on in
the world but it's like don't lose your
head I mean if you want to be President
I think your number one job requirement
is you cannot lose your head every time
something goes wrong you know you have
to sort of brace for it accept it learn
from it and move on and so on the
learning part any person who has been in
national security and any professional
interrogator will tell you information
garnered from torture waterboarding or
the extreme interrogation tactics that
were used in the early days after 9/11
didn't work it got us nothing it got us
nowhere it got us a bunch of detainees
who we can't even put through a criminal
court because we've tortured them right
because we don't want that evidence to
come out this is what it's gotten us and
so you know it's just it's it's not only
sort of an American it's just it doesn't
work like I don't even it's like talking
to a five-year-old you're like okay two
plus two does not equal five like two
plus two equals four and anyone who has
been in the interrogation world knows
that success and interrogation of a
hostile person right is generally a good
cop bad cop scenario right it's not it's
it's someone that they feel comfortable
with because they feel that they are
under stress in the environment that
they're in that they start to talk to
this toughness talk is masks any policy
and that's dangerous but it also and
this was what worries me is it once
again perpetuates this mythology that
you know a tough counterterrorism policy
will keep us a hundred percent say
from terrorism and if terrorism happens
it means you were too soft I just can't
be I mean as I said before it's like you
you tell me what country is whether it's
the toughest country in the world Israel
for example or the the least open
country in the world China or Myanmar
for example that doesn't have violence
perpetuated by people who would want who
want to have a political influence you
take the spectrum it's happening and
that's okay
I mean in a weird way it's like just
accept it it's a risk and then respond
brace and everything else for it